the moment Trump tweets it'll be the
most liked tweet in the history of
Twitter the moment he tweets it's going
to happen they're saying he's about to
by the way oh really his Camp is saying
he's about to okay Facebook and
Instagram is is slightly different on
why you let him back on uh could it be
ad money because ad money's taking a
massive hit with Facebook they're having
a hard time with that and they know if
Trump runs that campaign they're going
to spend a lot of AD money on Facebook
and the one that was a machine last time
was Facebook more than YouTube more than
Twitter more than everybody it was
Facebook Facebook was the machine that
helps with elections so they want that
money and that's a lot of money that
goes to Facebook right
um you know that could be one side the
other part is you know they they may
want him to come in to make it dirtier
against the Santas because he is going
to go against the scientist or it could
be a civil war where it could be them
going against each other and they like
that they want that